Goodwill compounds faster than money if
you actually think about what Goodwill
is it's that you have positive sentiment
and you have a degree of influence over
a person's Behavior if one person has
good will with you and then shares your
stuff with somebody else and you create
Good Will in that next person you can
double your Goodwill or 10x your
Goodwill in a matter of 12 weeks 10xing
your money in a matter of 12 weeks is
very very unlikely good will because
it's based on audiences and humans can
compound significantly faster than money
can and when I realize that that
Goodwill could be translated into money
if I so desired at a future date and
rather than focusing on the money that
I'm trying to make today why don't I
focus on the compounding vehicle that
compounds at a much faster rate than
money does that compound's tax-free by
the way and then when you choose to have
the conversion event you can do that at
your own choosing but if you focus on
the audience you focus on the Goodwill
that will grow significantly faster than
any kind of monetary move